[Music]
the reason why I chose us call more than
anything else is because underneath all
our skin is a skull
it's the universal image to everybody
the formative way they use artosis of
scholar desi traders who also nothing a
la Vida is salgan wave a young
[Music]
my name is butch locsin I'm a
contemporary performance artist here in
Los Angeles I were a skull mask and I
played with smoke grenades my word is
reflective of Mexican culture and
iconography and art work Maria saw a lot
of the photos that I was doing and she
wanted to actually collaborate on a
project and integrating her into what I
do has been really fun and successful
[Music]
Miami Maria there is a so unit ISTA
comments up in Pelican Athenian relative
impunity Nascimento solo kme plateau
bazooka maintain a me simple my Mustafa
mucho de los Muertos entonces cuando we
SWAT team a rock we there's the kosis
capoeira you tell Reza sir Cornell Maria
to me has been such a blessing because
now the characters the skeleton the
colors actually married to her and we've
been greeting like love scenes and
stories colaborate con el como que hace
una formal express army they develop
either not reform enough no Tomas
positiva I really like the David dead
holiday
it's not about celebrating someone's
death it's more about celebrating
someone's life my art working my
performance is kind of a little bit of a
reflection of that but even though I
kind of represent myself as like this
death character you know I'm very much
alive
me encanta lo que Pacho está siendo por
que pienso que si esta trend o es a
celebration a muchos lugar es on
la gente no no kono saz's tradicion es
mexicana SE Loa okay son
what I love about performance art is
honestly the brush that I get from
working with so many people you know
makes me want to go out there and create
some more and do something different lo
que estamos tratando the desert is n
computo exponent mas arte alguno algo
que nadie ha visto antes
[Music]
[Music]
people make assumptions all the time
so let's get the record straight if I
was a drug addict
how could I possibly have done all this
I'm Lisa Frank and this madness that you
see and all this excitement started with
me I know that you weren't comfortable
being on camera is there an element to
secrecy
well the secrecy has worked for so long
like I come out of the closet I don't
want to disappoint anybody what if I'm
not who they want me to be our look is
really been consistent for 30 years
and people have tried to tell me bright
colors are in you should do pastels and
it's not who I am we are entering the
vote that has all the original our
argument okay I better figure out how to
open it before you film it the room is
fireproof so that we don't use the
original art but look how bright
everything still is we were involved in
the big sticker craze in the eighties
then it went to school supplies because
a sticker is an inch to three inches so
it was more fun to get the art bigger
and you can see it says library sample
do not remove that means like it's
probably one of a kind in hindsight we
could have been even smarter like
keeping 12 of everything there are some
things I don't even have it was so
exciting because we were onto something
that no one else was really on to I mean
people thought I had horns coming out of
my head when I would suggest things
early on the buildings more than 300,000
square feet and at one time like every
Bay was filled up with drugs that was
shipping product out of here in the
beginning we probably had 30 artists at
one time unfortunately now we don't need
as many people in the art department
because things are much easier on the
computer so you now are doing only
licensing right now what we do is we do
the art work for a whole bunch of other
companies who are then making it and
shipping it I don't think I ever want to
be a manufacturer again that takes away
from Who I am and what I really love to
do is to do our work we want to round
out his face a little bit so he looks a
little cuter I've obviously learned a
ton over the years but in terms of the
artwork and the process I would say that
hasn't changed at all it was never about
making money it was about making good
product
[Music]
it's like my world is washed out and I
see fewer shades of color than most
people do so normal people see a million
colors I may see as many as a hundred
million my name is Wendy I'm a producer
at CNN and I am colorblind my name is
Maureen Seberg I'm a tetrachromats and
I'm an author tetrachromacy is the
presence of a fourth kun class in your
retina
if I keep naming my invisible colors
maybe I'll have my own Crayola box one
day when I was in kindergarten my
teacher called my parents because I was
coloring the leaves of my trees and the
trunks of my trees the same color
because I couldn't really see the
difference between green and brown the
only time it was ever overwhelming is a
paint contractor came to my house and
brought no fewer than 32 samples before
I was satisfied that it was a true beige
when I pick out clothes that's hard I
have been known to buy the outfit that
the mannequin is wearing because I know
that that goes together you don't want
to go clothing shopping with me because
the salespeople tell me but it matches
and I can only look at them
sympathetically and keep looking I never
think like oh if I weren't color blind
it would be so much easier to get
dressed in the morning it's just it's
kind of part of me I guess I'm a unicorn
or something
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in many many different cultures the
rainbow appears as a symbol of hope
beauty love in many ways the rainbow
flag might be more important than ever
[Music]
our story begins in San Francisco in the
late 1960s young gay men lesbian women
were arriving from all over the country
and all around the world many of them
fleeing places where they were
experiencing incredible violence and
repression one of those men was Gilbert
Baker everyone was aware of Gilbert
it was extremely dramatic I think the
operative word would be flamboyant
that's Cleve Jones he wrote this book
when we rise my life in the movement
Cleveland Gilbert met his two young
activists planning the 1977 San
Francisco gay pride event back that is
called a freedom day we were all part of
a circle of activists who were talking
about the need for a new symbol that
would connect us all and one day Gilbert
told Cleve about an idea he had come up
with he showed me the drawings he'd done
and I saw the power of it right away
and each other had special significance
one color meant love another was
honestly I think he kind of made that up
after the fact it came to him as he said
from the sky with a team of volunteers
including Cleve Gilbert sewed and dyed
the flags in preparation for gay freedom
day
when those first flags went up these
enormous polls and the wind took them
and lifted them up against the blue sky
it was really breathtaking hilburn I
stood there and watched and we knew that
everybody that was there was looking up
at those rainbows and knowing at that
exact moment that this now would be our
symbol to take this beautiful symbol
from nature and say this is the symbol
of these people who were called
unnatural who were required to live in
the shadows he really devoted his life
not only to making flags but banners for
a few weeks between the wet and dry
seasons this seemingly ordinary looking
River bursts to life with color
[Music]
Carnot crystallis is located in Mehta
Colombia when the conditions are just
right an endemic aquatic plant species
that lives in the riverbed blooms
creating a brilliant show of red color
often with hints of yellow orange green
and blue because of this locals refer to
the river
as the liquid rainbow or the river of
five colors before 2009 Meccano
crystallis was closed off to the public
due to guerrilla activity in the
surrounding region today the river can
be reached by horseback or by foot and
is accessible under the guidance of
local tour guides although this
phenomenon only happens for a short
period of time each year this living
rainbow leaves a lasting impression
[Music]